sí Raúl es que Ecuador lo tiene muy
cerca para conseguir avanzar a octavos
de final de un mundial por segunda vez
en su historia solamente un punto un
empate contra senegal en este cierre de
la fase de grupos para el grupo a
devastaría los dirigidos por Gustavo
Alfaro para meterse para avanzar en esta
copa mundo y seleccionador ecuatoriano
que hizo un llamado la calma la
Selección Ecuatoriana que viene
mostrando un buen nivel no ha perdido en
esta copa mundo una victoria contra
Qatar un empate contra Países Bajos es
el balance para esa selección en la que
seguramente estará en el Valencia
también lo dijo el profesor Gustavo
Alfaro va a ser muy difícil tener
valenciano juegue en esta copa mundo
pese a esas molestas que arrastra el
delantero ecuatoriano es el goleador eso
es uno de los goleadores de esta copa
mundo Ecuador que como decimos sueña con
ese empate contra los senegales es que
tiene que ganar que tiene para seguir
con vida en esta copa mundo en el otro
partido del grupo Países Bajos se mide
contra Qatar Países Bajos que también
con un empate avanza octavos de final
mientras Secada Busca un punto para no
ser la peor Barcelona en la historia de
los mundiales bueno Juan y otro partido
también importante de la jornada pero
sobre todo por su carga política es el
de Irán contra Estados Unidos que
podemos esperar de este encuentro
hay mucha expectativa máxima seguridad
para este encuentro Porque desde que
llegamos a Qatar cada vez que juega a
Irán se han visto demostraciones de
población iraní en rechazo a la
situación que se está produciendo en
este país desde la muerte de la joven
kurdo iraní macza Amin ha habido siempre
demostraciones en los dos partidos que
ha tenido Irán en esa derrota contra
Inglaterra y en esa Victoria contra
gales en el primer partido en el debut
de los iraníes los jugadores de Irán se
negaron a cantar el himno nacional para
hoy hay muchas expectativa tanto por esa
situación dirán como obviamente por el
antecedente político por las relaciones
políticas que hay entre Washington y
Teherán dos países que desde hace 40
años no tienen relaciones diplomáticas y
con ese antecedente del partido del
Mundial de Francia en 1998 en el estadio
de guerra que terminó con Irán ganando 2
a 1 a los norteamericanos la gran
diferencia con esta copa mundo y esta
actual en Qatar 2022 es que tanto
Estados Unidos como Irán se juega en el
duelo de esta noche nada menos y nada
más que un pase a octavos de final que
para la República islámica sería la
primera vez que avanzan a esta instancia
en una copa mundo